well today is the day folks this is the
day Captain Marvel is is finally coming
out I've been waiting for this moment
all I've been waiting for this moment my
my whole life actually I Captain Marvel
is without question and I can say this
as someone who has not seen it and never
will but it is without question the most
significant human achievement of the
last two thousand years at least
aside from Black Panther so it's well
Black Panther and moonlight and then
it's its third it's the third most
significant human achievement in two
thousand years and that's that's that's
pretty good I can't wait to not see it
by the way my favorite my favorite genre
of two was speaking of Captain Marvel my
favorite genre of tweet is is the one
where where people invent conversations
that they had with their woke kids so
you see this on Facebook sometimes to
where someone will make up this
conversation that they had with their
very enlightened you know is five year
old or eight year old I don't know
exactly why people do this i but you see
it all the time and it's not meant to be
it's hilarious but it's not meant to be
hilarious like we're actually supposed
to believe that the conversation
happened so here's one that someone just
posted I just saw this a guy named Kasim
Rasheed tweeted this verified account on
Twitter must be an important person he
this is a conversation he claims that he
had with his ten year old son so 10 year
old son all these Marvel movies this is
the first one with a female lead me yep
ten year old shaking my head I wish
women didn't have to wait till 1920 to
vote me why 10 year old I bet if they
could vote sooner we'd have more women
superhero leads by now and then him with
a mind blown emoji my favorite part of
that made of conversation where a
ten-year-old connects Captain Marvel to
women's suffrage my favorite thing is
that he claims that the ten-year-old
actually said the is actually said s mhm
shaking my head he actually said it now
I don't mind my kids not 10 year old but
it is
is that how ten-year-old speak now were
they actually shaking my head or they
narrate what they're doing because maybe
they do I don't know who knows all right
so so the the house yesterday passed a
resolution condemning hatred what is the
point of such a resolution well there is
no point there was a point to it
originally but but that point was lost
so originally it was supposed to to be a
resolution condemning specifically
anti-semitism and even more specifically
the anti-semitism of Ilan
Ilhan Omar the the freshman
representative democratic representative
who seemed to have a real problem with
Jews but Democrats her fellow Democrats
didn't want to condemn the views of a
Muslim woman so instead the resolution
ended up and this just is just a such a
perfect illustration of of the nature of
politics these days and especially of
the Democrat Party so originally it was
supposed to be a resolution condemning
Ilhan Omar's
anti-semitism but then it became a
resolution condemning all kinds of
hatred so this is what the actual
language says it condemns the hatred of
quote African Americans Native Americans
other people of color Jews Muslims
Hindus Sikhs immigrants and others they
just throw them all in there you know
throw in the whole the whole the whole
kit and caboodle but it didn't mention
Omar by name in fact Omar celebrated the
resolution pretending that it was a big
win for her you know she came out and
said finally we passed this resolution
condemning hatred because I hate
restrictor when originally it was
supposed to be a resolution condemning
her specifically and she knows that but
she's trying to turn it into a big win
for her now there are some people who
who are who seem to be confused about
why the Democrats would be so hesitant
to simply come out and register
officially their disapproval of Omar's
comments about Jews it seems like seems
like a pretty easy thing to do
especially when this I think the thing
that confuses people is that most Jewish
Americans are Democrats
so you're it's it's not like they would
be defending some demographic that isn't
part of their constituency because of
course they would never do that but the
American Jews are are in their
constituency yet they won't they don't
want to come out and do it and why is
that well this becomes less confusing
if you understand the victimization
flowchart okay now in the past I've
talked about this before in the past I
have called it and I think I've
contributed to some confusion
unfortunately because in the past I've
called it the the victimhood pyramid but
I think that terminology is a little bit
confusing it's really a flowchart okay
on the left they have a flowchart of
victimization so not so much of
victimhood but of victimization
literally charting the flow of
victimization from one group to another
so it goes like this all right so just
just imagine this in your mind first you
have white men okay and then the
victimization flows to white women and
then non-white men and then non-white
women and then gay men and then lesbian
women and then transgenders now the flow
of victimization starts with white men
which means that they victimize everyone
they cannot be victimized by anyone and
they victimize everyone and then on the
other hand and you have transgenders who
are victimized by everyone and can
themselves victimize no one so think of
it like a waterfall it can never be
reversed you got white men at the top
the oppression the persecution the
victimhood victimization it all flows
down and you can never reverse the flow
ever it always goes it's it is a one-way
street it can never go the other way
which means that white you know as I
said
white men cannot be victimized by anyone
white women cannot be victimized by nine
by non-white women black men cannot be
victimized by gay men it always goes
goes the other way right now in this
chart Jews are counted as white for the
purposes of the oppression Olympics and
for the left's victimhood equations
they're going to basically count Jews as
white which means that if you're a
Jewish man then you get lumped in with a
white man and and that's what you are so
you're in that category and it's just
you can't according to the left's way of
looking at things you you can't be a
victim of of bigotry
Ilhan Omar as a non white woman is
several steps away on the flowchart from
especially a Jewish man from the left
point of view and so she can't really be
guilty of bigotry against Jews that's
what it comes down to it just cannot
happen and I'm not making this up but
this is not just mean just being
flipping and well it is also me being
flipped but but it's not just that this
is this is really what the left team
this is what they teach in Kyle you send
your kid to college if you're spending
you know $100,000 to send your kid to
college this is what he's learning okay
this is what you're paying for him to
learn you know what give me the $100,000
and I'll tell you a kid about this
letting me I can brainwash your kid into
leftist into the leftist orthodoxy if
you want if you give me hundred thousand
I would do that for you because you know
what I'll do it for 50 grand so only now
if when they teach it in college they
don't teach it as a victimization
flowchart
they would talk about it in terms of
privilege alright so what they would say
is that white men are the most
privileged and then it goes on from
there and each person if you each person
with more privilege cannot be victimized
by someone with less this yeah this is
literally what they teach white men have
all the privilege
and so they cannot be victims of bigotry
they could be victims of um you know of
in in other senses they can be the
victim of a carjacking or something but
they cannot be it's impossible to be
racist against them it's impossible to
be sexist against them it's impossible
to be bigoted it's impossible that's
what they say so now this gets a little
bit more complicated because you might
point out that Muslims are rarely
condemned for homophobia so doesn't that
put them at the end of the victim
flowchart as the victim iasts victims of
all instead of as I and I put
transgenders at the at the end of it but
wouldn't it actually be Muslims because
it seems like no matter you know they
don't they're never condemned for for
homophobia even though you see
especially in Muslim countries not just
homophobia but you see violent anti-gay
bigotry so well this becomes kind of an
intense debate this this is a subject of
intense debate among victimology on the
left and I think that there's a there's
a difference of opinion I'm not gonna
wait into it I'm not an expert on this
so I can't really I can't decree on that
except I will say that I think I think
the reluctance to condemn Muslims
especially when it comes to the anti-gay
stuff that that's more about the left
determination to keep the homophobia
claims focused on white Christians so
it's that's really what it's about it's
it's not that they categorically refuse
to condemn homophobia in the Muslim
world it's just more that if they're
gonna talk about homophobia they want to
talk about the ultimate villains who are
white Christians if white Christians
didn't exist if all white Christians
were were to evaporate which I'm sure
would be a a reason for for great
celebration among many on the left if
that were to happen then I think maybe
they would maybe maybe then they would
find some time
talk about all the gays being thrown off
roofs and Saudi Arabia and so on so
that's that's just how it works and the
chart the chart can change by the way
all right now white men will always be
on that end of it incapable of being
victimized by anyone but the other
positions can move around and shift and
so there's a little bit of jockey
there's a competition within within
these groups to be more victimized than
the other and so that's that's always
going that's very fascinating to watch
that soap opera play out and so you see
how from from this there are many forms
of actual oppression and many oppressed
groups that just don't count
they aren't noticed Jews are arguably
the most oppressed group in history
period yet that oppression doesn't
really register on the left it doesn't
really they don't really count it the
Irish I mean are also a very
historically oppressed group there
aren't many groups that have had a
harder time of it than the Irish but
again it doesn't really count it doesn't
register they don't really count that
because their skin color is just way too
light there are in fact there are there
are whole historical events and eras
that have to be wiped from the history
books because they so contradict the
victimization flowchart the Barbary
slave trade for instance where to hunt
for two hundred years hundreds of
thousands of white Europeans were
kidnapped bought and sold as slaves by
Africans and that whole 200 years slice
of history has been a race they don't
talk about it at school you're not going
to find it in the history books because
it is such a complete contradiction of
the victim narrative and so they can't
they cannot talk about it they have to
they have nothing they can say about it
they have to pretend it never happened
and that's basically how
intersectionality works and it requires
you to make all of these emissions and
to censor this and to forget about that
and it becomes very very confused and
it's why
it's best not to adopt that mentality
and instead to just instead of having
this complicated ideology of victimhood
to look at things on a case-by-case
basis all right let's see okay I wanted
to I want to have mentioned this is kind
of a comparatively small and petty thing
but I think it's it's worth noting it's
it's pettiness is what makes it so
revealing and therefore worth noting it
was a there was something happened
yesterday that I thought was a very
revealing moment okay so the the far
left there's a a website called Ross
story it's a far left website and it
they very often publish misleading
dishonest articles about conservatives
and yesterday they published one of
their typically dishonest hit pieces and
they were claiming that a conservative
is boy cow to boycotting Girl Scout
cookies because Alexandria kzo Cortes
used to be a girl scout that was the
claim and that's the claim that they
make right in the headline they say the
headline is from Ross story the headline
is conservative calls for cookie boycott
because aoc used to be a girl scout
now the conservative is a columnist for
a WorldNetDaily and her name is Jane
Chastain if you actually take a brief
look at her piece that is being referred
to here on on worldnetdaily you see that
the raw story headline and the article
is a rather predictable Distortion
in truth what the what the author is
saying is that she's not gonna be buying
the cookies and she never calls for a
boycott she never uses the word boycott
or calls for everybody to stop by she
just says she's not gonna buy the
cookies because of the overall political
and ideological shift that the Girl
Scouts have undergone over the past
several years and she's this is it's
it's very true she accuses the
organization correctly
of pushing God and country and those
values to the backseat in favor of
left-wing causes and ideas and she cites
for example the Girl Scouts well-known
affiliation with Planned Parenthood we
talked about that yesterday
Alexandra occasional cortez is mentioned
only because the Girl Scouts celebrated
her election on their website so this
author uses that as an example of the
Girl Scouts political bias and then at
one point she says you know Alexandra
okay okay secret says what was a Girl
Scout and she Cortez represents sort of
the ideological shift of the Girl Scouts
and so if you don't want your daughter
to end up like her and have her values
then don't send her into the Girl Scouts
but she never calls for she never calls
for a boycott at all and she certainly
doesn't call for a boy for a boycott
because Cortez used to be a Girl Scout
that's not at all what happened so it's
a dishonest headline in a leftist online
rag and certainly not the first won't be
the last in and of itself not a big deal
if it weren't for the fact that Cortez
herself seized on that headline that lie
and she amplified it which is what she
does all the time
so Cortez posted a screenshot of raw
stories headline on Twitter with our own
snappy little caption where you know she
mocks conservatives for boycotting Girl
Scout cookies for such a dumb reason and
her followers of course jumped on the
bandwagon they were heaping scorn on all
the stupid conservatives who are
boycotting the Girl Scouts for such a
stupid reason meanwhile in reality Ville
no conservative is boycotting anything
for that reason nobody is saying we're
gonna boycott this or that organization
because Alexandria okay zo Cortez used
to be in it nobody a segment but notice
the effort on Cortez is part because
the most natural thing would be if you
see an article online and there's
something about it that you want to
share what do you do you just share the
article that would be the most natural
thing but notice how instead she takes a
screenshot of the articles headline and
then crops it down
you know MIT takes that little bit of
effort and post the screenshot to
Twitter why did she do that rather than
just posting the article because she
knows that the headline is dishonest and
if you're able to actually click on the
headline and go read the article you're
going to quickly discover that it's
dishonest and she doesn't want anyone to
do that so instead she just put the
screenshot there knowing that most
people aren't going to take the effort
to actually go to Google and investigate
they're just gonna take it at its at its
word like I said it's a smutty a petty
thing or Smitty is what I just combined
it that's a small and petty it is a
small petty thing but this is the small
pettiness that Alexandra Kaiser Cortez
thrives on this kind of thing she's
obsessed with the idea that
conservatives are constantly attacking
her for dumb reasons she's constantly
looking for opportunities to make
herself into the victim of unfair
ridiculous attacks by conservatives and
in in almost every case not every case
but in almost every case the attacks are
either absurdly exaggerated or invented
out of whole cloth but she's always
looking for this to do this and this is
not another case where she's she's
promoting this lie to try to make
conservatives look stupid and also to to
continue the narrative that everyone's
talking about her and it's all about her
so to put it more directly Cortez is a
lying propagandist she's not the first
of that type to walk the halls of
Congress she won't be the last but her
lies and propaganda tend to be more
damaging than usual because of her
platform and because she so successfully
plays the kind of a fun innocent
idealist unfairly maligned by petty
right-wing lunatic
card that's the card that she's always
playing and she plays it well and
dishonestly and and so it's very
effective and in the process all she's
doing is creating more division sewing
more suspicion and contempt into the
culture into a culture that has more
than enough of those things already and
and so that's just the latest example
and I found it to be yeah I just found
it to be contemptible and the fact that
it's such a small thing is what makes it
even more contemptible it's like you
couldn't have really you had to latch on
to that you couldn't just let that go
you saw your name in a headline and it
was attached to this so you had to put
it out there you could you couldn't have
moved on from that alright um let's
start answering emails a little bit
earlier because there are a few good
ones that I want to have a chance to get
into Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
well show at gmail.com so we'll go to
the inbox this is from Jesse he says
Matt I listened to your show from a few
weeks ago a few days ago when a listener
asked about your opinion about women
being drafted I agree with both of your
opinions however it struck a chord with
me when you said I'm paraphrasing that
sense he had lived through it and is an
expert his opinion is what matters not
mine why does that same response not
ring true for kids who've lived through
say say for example school shooting and
want to abolish the Second Amendment
because they're now experts since
they've lived through it I should be
asking myself the same question because
these kids are not experts what say you
yeah that's an interesting question this
is actually one of my one of my many pet
peeves is when people act like personal
experience automatically confers special
knowledge or wisdom and makes them an
authority on a certain subject
experience does not always confer
knowledge or you know wisdom now in the
case of the draft yeah that was an email
from someone who fought on the front
lines was a veteran and was of the
opinion of the same opinion of almost
every veteran I've spoken to about this
issue his opinion was we should be
drafting women and we shouldn't have
women on the front lines now in that
case I said
his experience does make him an
authority because I think being on the
front lines of comment does give you
special relevant knowledge when it comes
to this issue you're going you're going
to know more about modern combat how it
works the practical considerations the
psychological effects etc and and so if
a bunch of people who've all had that
experience are all saying no we
shouldn't draft women no we shouldn't
have women on the front lines of comment
then I think that carries a lot of
weight because yeah if you that's one of
those things where if you've done it
then your you are going to know a thing
or two about it and you're probably
going to know more than people who've
never been there that doesn't end the
conversation their word is not the first
last and only word that anyone can speak
everyone else has a right to contribute
to the discussion and you could have
plenty of valuable things to contribute
to that discussion even if you've never
been to war but I think this is a case
where experience because of the nature
of the experience does involve knowledge
creates and confers knowledge right on
the other hand being in the proximity of
a school shooting does not confer
knowledge about the Second Amendment or
about constitutional law or about guns
or about anything really except the
emotional impact and psychological
personal trauma of being involved in
something like that and and that's so
that is a perspective that's it's it's a
valuable perspective but but it's not a
perspective that really has anything to
do with gun rights it's a non sequitur
it's a non second or sequiturs to say
well their school was shot up therefore
we should listen to them about the
Second Amendment no being in war
requires knowledge about war being
involved in a school shooting does not
require any knowledge about anything
it's something that happens to you
tragically in much the same way that
getting cancer doesn't make you a doctor
but as I said this is something people
do a lot where they try to shut down a
conversation by saying oh yeah well I've
been through this have you been through
it listen to my experience and often I
would say most of the time their
personal experience doesn't really make
their opinion more credible at all
sometimes it makes it sometimes it
actually can arguably make it in some
ways less credible like for example when
when when we've had debates about ADHD
and I make certain philosophical points
about the human condition and the sort
of flawed methodology involved in
calling something a disorder I make
points about neuroscience and so on I'm
not an expert in any of those things but
I'm making points about them I can study
them and think about them just same as
anyone can and and I always get people
in fact the conversation always every
time always devolves into people
shouting at me that well my son has ADHD
and you don't know what you're talking
but I've been through it you don't know
what it's like okay what does that have
to do with the objective realities we're
discussing that doesn't make me wrong
and it doesn't make you right just
because your son has ADHD does not make
you an expert it simply doesn't and in
fact it could make you it could cloud
your ability to judge this objectively
because if you gift your kid has it
you've already got them on drugs well
then now you've got an incentive to to
justify the decision you've already made
so there's going to be a bias there
doesn't mean that we should listen to
your perspective I'm not saying that I'm
just saying that there's also a clear
bias that you have now as well so
whatever whatever knowledge your
experience might confer I think it sort
of canceled out by the bias that you
have in trying to justify decisions
you've already made so you know another
one is talking about abortion and
someone says what you've never had an
unwanted pregnancy you don't know what
it's like again not relevant it's simply
not that that has nothing to do with the
objective issues we're discussing so
bringing up your protein this is why I
don't like it is that when people
do it in many cases what it really
amounts to nothing more than emotional
blackmail they're trying to shut that it
is not about enhancing the discussion or
advancing the discussion
it's about shutting it down and using
their own personal issues as a kind of
sledgehammer to bludgeon everyone with
and to say you're not allowed to talk
about this I'm the one who's been
through it I have suffered so your
opinion doesn't count
and I really I just I have come so much
to dislike that strategy I really do and
I again there are exceptions but I just
I can't stand it anytime there are
people that you can't anytime you try to
have a conversation about anything
there's always someone who ruins it by
getting into the getting into some
emotional personal story that it doesn't
it doesn't advance the discussion all it
means is that now the rest of us can't
be honest about our opinions anymore
because you have emotionally blackmailed
us and said that well just so you know
guys if you're honest about your
opinions you're gonna hurt my feelings
because here's my person looks bad I
really I don't like it all right from
Connor he says Matt I think hi Matt I
think in your show yesterday you
confused atheism with agnosticism you
said that atheism doesn't require faith
because atheism is just the lack of
faith that's not correct agnosticism is
a lack of belief I don't know atheism is
a belief that God does not exist hope
this helps clear things up hi Connor I
think you're mistaken actually and this
is a common misunderstanding that people
have I and I'm in the weird position now
of it's almost like I'm defending
atheism or something I'm not defending
atheism but what I'm doing is I'm trying
to define our terms I think it's
important to define our terms to know
what we're dealing with so most people
think that agnosticism is as you said I
don't know and atheism is I know that
God doesn't exist that's not really true
and if you listen
to pretty much any sophisticated
thoughtful intelligent atheist they will
absolutely not say I know God doesn't
exist they're not going to say that
they're gonna be more careful than that
they might say in regards to a
particular theological system or a
particular God they might say I know
that God doesn't exist but again these
are the thoughtful sophisticated I'm not
talking about the atheists or in a
comment section on YouTube I'm talking
about the you know the ones the Sam
Harris's of the world they are so they
might say it about about about a
particular theological system they're
not going to say it about the kind of
general concept of God to include the
deistic concept of a sort of first mover
who's got everything going and is now
somewhere not paying attention right so
now they make they may think that or
feel that way that they know that God
doesn't exist but that's not the way
they formulate their argument they're
gonna speak in terms of probabilities
and so they're going to say something
like based on current evidence it seems
improbable that God exists something
along those lines
now again I think they're probably being
more cautious in their wording of the
argument than they actually are in their
convictions inside their heads but we
could only engage with the arguments as
they're presented not as we think the
presenter really means them which is
which the point that I made about people
do that that's theist atheist do that to
us all the time where they they act like
the claim we're making is that God is a
bearded man in the sky who is sitting up
there with his big staff or whatever on
a literal literal throne in the clouds
looking down on us and so that's the
argument that they often engage with but
that's that's that's not the argument
that a sophisticated intelligent
thoughtful Christian or theist makes
there may be some more immature
Christians who do think of God in those
terms
but as an atheist your responsibility is
to engage with the sophisticated
arguments that your opponents are
actually making not the argument that
you think they're thinking right so I I
think on both sides it's what we have to
do so here's how it really breaks down
eith agnosticism has that root gnosis or
not stick right so think of the ancient
not Gnostics the Christian Gnostics who
believe that spiritual liberation was
attained through divine knowledge not
through atonement but through knowledge
that's what they believed
so and there's still strands of
Gnosticism around today I mean I have a
friend who's a kabbala stand you know I
talked to him about it's not it's not
Christian it's more of a that's a
offshoot of Judaism but and and I've
talked to him about Cobble ISM many
times and I've always tried to pin it
down with him like what is this exact
what do you say except Japan theistic is
it what is it but as I've studied more
about Gnosticism I've realized that okay
he's a he's a gnostic as what yes anyway
so it's so not system was all about
knowledge right gnosis knowledge gnosis
means knowledge
a true agnostic believes not only that
God is God's existence is unknown but
this is what a real agnostic okay
believes that God's existence is
unknowable it cannot be known it is
outside of our comprehension we cannot
know it so in that way agnosticism is
actually more dogmatic than atheism in a
sense an atheist on the other hand is a
non theist that is a literal definition
of the term hey non-theist someone who
is not a theist that's what an atheist
is an atheist doesn't believe in theism
is not a theist there is no positive
truth claim necessarily involved in
atheism now every atheism does make
positive truth claims but just the the
generic form of atheism does not make a
claim it rejects a claim so an atheist
is is is seeking to shift the burden of
proof back to the theist
saying you simply haven't proven your
your assertion therefore I don't believe
it but the common thing that you hear
from atheists all the time is they'll
say that well you know referring to
atheism it's like it's like calling
someone a nonstampcollector you know
it's like defining someone by a hobby
they don't have and you know I think
that that's that's a reductive and
oversimplifying on their part but again
just the absolute generic form of
atheism that is kind of what it is it is
a not it is a non so it's all about the
nature of knowledge it's kind of an
epistle histological discussion
ultimately so an agnostic says we cannot
know of God a theist says we do know of
God an atheist says we don't know of God
so you look at it like this take a non
theological claim say that I say that I
claimed that the universe is exactly 100
trillion light years across okay the
whole universe let's say I said is
exactly 100 trillion light years across
the atheist response to that claim is to
say I don't believe your assertion
because I don't think you have evidence
for it and it seems like you made it up
maybe you're right but I don't there's
no reason to believe it because you
don't have sufficient reasoning for your
belief the agnostic response is to say
nobody can ever know exactly how big the
universe is it's simply outside of our
scope of knowledge we'll never know and
I have nothing else to say about it
other than that the theists response is
to affirm the claim now in that
particular example of the size of the
universe I'm more of the agnostic I
don't I don't think we could ever know
how big the universe really is when it
comes to God I'm atheist because I think
there is good evidence good evidentiary
reasoning for believing but more
importantly I also believe because and
this is where faith comes in I believe
because of the internal witness of the
Holy Spirit which is faith and which has
we must admit no evidentiary value to
anyone outside of myself so the fact
that I have this internal conviction
that I believe is granted from the Holy
Spirit I can't give
to you I experienced it within myself
which doesn't mean that it did it that
it has no value in affirming a claim I
believe that it does but it isn't its
internal in such in much the same way
that my internal conviction about the
love I have for my wife is extremely
evidentiary for me but not for anyone
else so for anyone else if I tell them
that I love my wife and they ask for
proof for evidence well I cannot put
them inside my head so that they are
inside my heart's my soul so that they
can experience the love that I have for
my wife which is in experience more than
an emotion but I could provide summit
but inside could show them that okay
I've done this and that for my wife you
know I could I could show her the things
that I could show this person the things
that I've done to prove it and so that
is some good evidence that I love my
wife but it doesn't tell the whole story
because the whole story of love is not
external it is external and internal and
so I would be diminishing and cheapening
love if I claimed that I could
completely and totally prove it through
external things because I would be
removing the entire internal experience
of love and I think God who is love is
like that in my view there's the
external indications experience evidence
of God which I find to be compelling
quite compelling but then there is also
the internal experience which is faith
and which
not something that we should be
embarrassed by so that's where this all
this all came from this thing where
Christians do or they say Oh a theists
have more faith than us
why are you treating faith like a dirty
word why are you why are you embarrassed
by it you shouldn't be no they don't
have more we have more faith in them our
view requires faith theirs does not and
that's okay if you think there's
something wrong with that then I then it
seems to me that that's kind of a you
need to work that out that's a problem
right because faith is a virtue faith
hope and love right so I I don't I don't
understand I don't understand why many
Christians are dead set on this idea
that atheists have to have faith what's
why can't you admit they don't unless
you think that there's something wrong
with faith which in that case why are
you a Christian
all right finally from Maria says hi
Matt loved the show I've been wanting to
write to you about a show you did months
ago about introversion it was such a
huge help to me as an introvert myself I
always feel very out of place in the
world I was fascinated to find out that
you are also an introvert because you're
so outspoken and I know you're going
around giving speeches as well I could
never do that as an introvert my
question is how did you overcome your
introversion in order to do what you do
for a living
Maria thanks for the message you know I
didn't overcome it at all and I don't
think of it as something that needs to
be overcome I think it's awesome that
you're an introvert and I don't think
you need to look at it as something that
you have to get past or overcome or
whatever I so I wouldn't look at it like
that it's not like there's something
wrong with you it's there isn't
something that needs to be fixed or
changed because of this so introversion
as I said in that show that it's not the
same thing as shyness you can you can be
a non shy introvert just like you could
be a shy extrovert and my wife is kind
of like my wife is a huge my wife is a
quintessential extrovert
in every sense but she also has a
certain shyness to her which is which is
which which would shock anyone who
anyone who doesn't know her very well
will be shocked by that to find out that
she has a certain shyness to her but she
does in that she can be apprehensive
sometimes in a social situation but then
once she gets into it you know she's a
social butterfly she's talking and she
and she loves it didn't she and she just
enjoys the experience she's very
energized by it but there is that little
bit of sometimes apprehension leading
into the situation so you know I I I'm
not shy at all I'm not I I not only can
I get up in front of a crowd of people
and speak to them but I enjoy it and in
fact the bigger the crowd is the more I
enjoy it I am more comfortable I've I've
spoken in front of a group of a thousand
people I've spoken in front of a group
of ten people and I really prefer the
thousand two one thousand the smaller
groups make me less comfortable and the
least comfortable comfortable at all of
all for me is what I have to have an
individual small talk conversation I
would much prefer to be Aquifer of
everybody in talking so that's not
shyness that is because yes shyness is
you don't wanna get on the stage
that's just introversion that's what
that is being an introvert simply means
that you feel energized by not so much
by small talk and social interaction but
by time alone time to yourself you enjoy
being in your own head thinking
contemplating whatever this is
definitely me again my wife is not like
that she does like you know time to
herself but a lot of times she'll say
you know can I get a break I get some
time to myself and of course she needs
that as well but then a lot of times
she'll spend that time on the phone
talking to her friend or something
she'll call up whenever one of her
girlfriends and talk on the phone you
know and now to me that's completely I
can't even it's mind-boggling to me like
you want time alone you want a break and
so you're on the phone to me being on
the phone is the worst thing is the most
draining thing I hate talking on the
phone but for her that's what she enjoys
so that's extrovert introvert as an
introvert it's draining to be in a
social situation doesn't mean you you
fear it doesn't mean you hate it
but it is draining it saps your energy
and it's not where you feel the most at
home and the most comfortable and and
okay so that's there's nothing wrong
with that at all it's okay to be that
way it's great to be that way you don't
need to overcome it you don't need to
change it or fix it
the world needs introverts okay the
world needs I mean we can't all be
talking 24/7 right so the world needs I
think the world needs both types and
just to make that point I talk to people
all the time it seems like it's a very
common set up apparently to have
introverts and extroverts from getting
married and because then there's you
know opposites attract and all that but
there's also kind of you know you kind
of get both you get both bases sort of
covered in that way and so it works and
I think it shows that we need that in
society as well even though I think
society is skewed to be more accepting
and encouraging of extroverts which
means that we are victims okay I think
we belong to be we should be on the
victimhood flowchart somewhere we are
persecuted all right
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening and I'll talk to you next week
Godspeed